well the new year is dominated by
concerns about the NHS and rail strikes
of course joining us now is the
transport secretary Mark harpermark uh
Harper Happy New Year to you good
morning Happy New Year to you and we're
going to come on to the Royal Strokes of
course in a moment I want to start with
the A E I know if you've been watching
our show this morning we had a chapel
called Matthew Simpson who talks about
his wife Teresa who died waiting 16
hours at any I mean what do you say to a
family that has had to wait all that
time to get treated in our Health
Service well look I didn't didn't see
the package but obviously my enormous
sympathies are with that family and
that's clearly not an acceptable length
of time for anybody to wait and I
recognize that the Health Service is
under pressure this winter that's why
the government's made extra resources
available not actually just for the
Health Service but also importantly for
social care to make sure that people who
are well enough to leave Hospital are
able to do so we made extra resources
available so that that help can get onto
the front line and that's what I know
ministers are working very hard to do so
I accept it's tough at the moment
because we're dealing with the you know
results of the pandemic high level of
flu and the normal winter pressures on
top of that but that's why we've made
those extra resources available on
helping families like Matthew Simpsons
and not helping those families but
you've seen reports people had to wait
99 hours for treatment yes and one of
the real issues is about making sure
that people who are well enough to leave
Hospital are able to leave that's why
it's important that the Health and
Social Care Systems are working together
that's why we made half a billion pounds
500 million pounds available before
Christmas and that money is getting to
local councils and local health services
so they can work together to to get the
system unblocked and that's what will
then feed through into a faster response
into emergency departments and a faster
response for ambulance so when are
people going to see that because it's
not just that money I mean that money is
very welcome of course everyone will say
that but this is years and years of
under investment in the health services
no well I don't agree with that we put
of extra money into the Health Service
every single year and there's record
levels of investment into the Health
Service in real terms we've got uh
thousands more doctors and thousands
more nurses working in the Health
Service you know there are 130 000
vacancies in the Health Service there
are huge discrepancies in those figures
well no look there are significantly
more doctors and nurses working in the
Health Service we do think it's
important to look at Workforce uh in the
long term that's why the chance to set
that out in the Autumn statement and
that's why the Health Service is working
on that long-term Workforce for a plan
at the moment which will be published in
the coming months okay let's come on to
your brief and the transport strikes
there was reporting before Christmas
that ministers have got involved at the
last minute and have put a block on a
deal being signed between the union and
the rail delivery groups is that true no
that absolutely isn't true in fact since
I became transport secretary a couple of
months ago I met all the union leaders I
tried to change the tone of the
discussions and I said that ministers
would help facilitate the trade unions
and the employers that's the train
operating company's Network rail getting
around the table I made sure there was a
new and improved offer that went to
trade Union members that's why two of
the unions have settled on network rail
the rmt recommended though sadly that
their members should reject that but
even so a third of their members wanted
to accept it so look I think in the New
Year it's time for the rmt to get off
the picket line background the
negotiating table the ministers will do
what we can to facilitate them coming to
a deal with the employers I want to get
these rail disputes sorted out for the
benefit of the traveling public so
there's no Clause that's been asserted
at the last minute about driver-only
trainers driver only change is not a new
thing they've been um they've been in
place the unions it's always been a red
line they've been in place since the
1990s 55 of people that use trains are
all in Services where there are driver
only operation Workforce reform is
important we've got to get rid of some
of these outdated working practices so
for example we can have a proper
seven-day Railway where the rail service
isn't dependent on people being rosted
to work on their days off that doesn't
deliver a good service for for
passengers so we need modern Railway a
there's a fair and reasonable offer on
the table and I hope the rmt looked to
take it I mean you know that the rmts
say that they work seven days a week and
it's not an issue about rostering they
say that there's not enough staff as
well which is perhaps part of the
problem on those Sundays when people
aren't no look this is this is because
there are days of the week when people
don't have to work they're not
contracted to work and the rail service
depends on what's called rest day
working which is where people are
rostered to work on their days off and
if they don't want to come to work the
training companies find it very
difficult to run those Services that's
not a way to run a modern Railway we
need a proper seven-day Railway where
people are rostered on each day and have
to come to work on each day they're
contracted to work so that you can
deliver better services for passengers
it's that sort of Reform with a fair pay
package that we want to see to resolve
this decision has that been offered
there has been a fair and reasonable
offer on the table which is comparable
to what most people listening to this
program will have got across the economy
two trade unions accepted it that offer
from Network rail the rmt are holding
out against it and I hope they get
background in negotiating table off the
picket lines and we can try and hammer
out a deal between the employers and the
trading they're saying they want to talk
to you they said they've had no contact
for the past couple of weeks well no
look they met the rail minister so the
employers trade unions and the rail
Minister met before Christmas the rail
ministers continue to talk to them
across the Christmas period and we're
looking to have more meetings set up
next week I'd much rather those meetings
took place this week instead of strikes
taking place
um and that would be my message to the
Trade union why are they taking place
this week then well because the Trade
union
because the trade unions decided they
wanted to go on strike this week which
is deeply unhelpful damages the rail
industry damages the interest of the
people that work in it I want to see
them back around the table we can try
and hammer out a deal between the
employers and the trade Unions that's
what I want to see happen that's what
I'm doing working really hard with the
rail minister to try and sort out is
there going to be an increase in the
offer to these striking workers in terms
of their benefits well look there's a
fair and reasonable payoff for on the
table people that there's not a
bottomless pit of taxpayers money here
the taxpayers put a huge amount of
investment into the rail industry over
the last few years when it was hit with
a huge impact from the pandemic when
people weren't traveling and I think
it's you've got to have an offer that's
both fair to the people that work in the
industry but it's also fair to the
taxpayer that's picking up the tab and
that's the balance that we're trying to
strike I mean just a broader thought
about the government that you you
represent in Europe seeing all this
strike actions how does that feel
working in a government that has so many
people within the public sector and the
private sector out on strike because of
the the say the economy and the way that
they feel the country is being right
well look it's not a surprise at the
moment with inflation being very high
we're seeing High inflation you know
driven by uh the war in Ukraine the high
energy prices it's not surprising that
people are under pressure that's why the
governments try to make reasonable
payoffers in the public sector it's why
for example we've accepted the
independent pay review borders in the
health service for example which was
above the government's own affordable
ability constraints but accepted that
offer in full to try and give people a
fair pay rise but look I accept things
are difficult at the moment we want to
try and get inflation back under control
that's the way that will help everybody
in the economy that's definitely the
ambition and do you ex do you accept
that more can be done by government to
try and get this resolve people are
asking questions about where the Prime
Minister has been people are asking
questions about Parliament being
recalled this week to try and resolve
some of these issues well the Prime
Minister has been working I think had a
short break and for Christmas day it's
been working across the Christmas period
we put in place those uh offers before
Christmas or pay we've accepted the pay
review bodies recommendations in the
health service for example and I think
ministers are going to continue trying
to do what we can to resolve these
disputes but as I said it has to be fair
both for the people that work in the
public sector but also for the taxpayer
that has to meet those bills that's what
the government's going to continue
trying to do now you said you've not
been able to speak to the rmt so far
this week you'd like to but I'm going to
be speaking to little while's time what
would you want to say to to Mick Lynch
well I I had a perfectly constructive
meeting when I met Mick Lynch after I
took on this job I'd say look the real
Minister's trying to get some more
meetings sorted out history let's get
off the picket line let's get around the
negotiating table I made sure there was
an improved offer that went to Trade
union members let's try and Hammer out
the detail you get these disputes
resolved around the negotiating table
not on the picket line and that would be
my message to Mr Lynch okay Mark Harper
Transportation pleasure thank you very
much